[Music]
remember the Nunez memo well back in
February the house Intel committee under
the leadership of Devin Nunez made
public a memorandum alleging the FBI
abused its authority in obtaining a FISA
warrant against former Trump campaign
aide Carter page well over the weekend
the Trump administration released the
previously top secret FISA warrant used
against Paige and the Washington
Examiners Byron New York opined that the
new documents bolstered the núñez memo
but the Washington Post's Philip bump
had a completely different take writing
that the warrant damaged Nunez his
credibility so try to sort it all out
well let's bring in Congressman Devin
Nunez himself congressman good so first
interview since this come out what do
you what do you think about the
criticism we're really happy that it
came out we've been fighting for this
for months for this FISA application
there's it's the FISA and the three
renewals to be put out for the public to
see there's still a lot of redactions we
would like for all those to be
unredacted so that the American public
has a chance to see this in full
transparency now what some watch some
this is just a sliver of the criticism
that you've received nine oh no that's
nothing yet for you but over the weekend
after this was released let's watch he
basically wrote this entire memo to
mislead the American public without ever
having read this FISA application they
were lying when they said that that the
FISA judges were fooled because they
were not told that part of the base of
the of the application Devon Nunez
acting is a useful idiot for the Russian
government your reaction some of that I
enjoy it just bring it on the more that
they do the more that they attack the
more that we know were right over the
target they cannot deny what was the
major point of the memo was to say that
the dossier was used in this application
and it made up the bulk of the FISA you
even with the redactions you can see
that that's the case I want to ask you
about that particular part this quote
from a FISA expert David Chris on the
warrant application on the website law
fair this is what he said now we can see
that the footnote to
closing steals possible bias takes up
more than a full page in the
applications there's literally no way
the FISA Court could have missed it the
FBI gave the court enough information to
evaluate Steele's credibility and that
basic points being repeated quite often
by the left so one of the things you
have to realize now with all the press
is the press certain members of the
press work for the Democratic Party and
the law fair blog has been one of them I
mean they've been every day there's some
new attack out and so I don't put a lot
of credibility into what they say the
fact of the matter is is that you you
have to present verified information to
the court and let's not forget to open
up a counterintelligence investigation
into a campaign unprecedented but then
to to use these invasive types of
capabilities in on an American citizen
that should be very very seldom used in
this case not only did they use it but
they used it with information from the
other candidates campaign and it wasn't
verified well what they said about steal
or what they put in the application is
that there was reason to trust him they
don't refer to him by name yeah source
number one so they said well there's
reason he's credible because other
information source number one had given
us had led to criminal convictions is
that not that's good enough for you that
that is not that's all it's absolutely
not the case I mean if we're gonna go to
secret courts and you're in first of all
I believe it doesn't follow the rules
and regulations just because a source
was good in one case doesn't mean that
the next time they're gonna bring
information forward that it's not going
to be that it doesn't have to be
verified this is a secret court that
information must be vetted and verified
but they didn't name a number of other
people and we have that we have a full
page of the the application that we'll
put up on the screen but there are a lot
of people who weren't named so there
were candidate one number one candidate
number two source number one source
number two and you can see it in the
actual you know and the actual that's
why you had to use that you really had
to use like word puzzles to get to how
they described in that footnote where
they supposedly told the court that it
was paid for by the Democrat
so know that it was possibly they
speculate it could be but they didn't
say that specifically they said in
opposition to the president correct
that's correct but they could have
easily said that it was paid for by
candidate number two and they did not
say that
why IB I believe because that's crazy I
mean can you imagine do we live in a
country today well I guess we do
actually live in a country because this
actually did happen but where we can
just go higher you know private you know
former contractors to go out and and in
this case a British a former British
agent to go dig up dirt on your opponent
take it to the FBI DOJ that you control
feed it into them so that they can open
up a counterintelligence investigation
without any defense there without any
grand jury and go and get all of your
communications and look that's why they
wanted to have Carter page that's why
they wanted to all have his electronic
communications like I keep hearing this
argument well it wasn't till after he
was off the campaign in the FISA
operation itself it says that they
believe he's the guy that's running this
collusion effort yeah so clearly they
think he's still involved in the
campaign and clearly this guy had his
rights abused Marco Rubio actually made
that point let's watch I don't think
they did anything wrong I think they
went to the court they got the judges to
approve it they put laid out all the
information and there was a lot of
reasons unrelated to the dossier for why
they wanted to look at Carter page and
Carter page was not a key member of the
Trump campaign but and the Trump
campaign has said that so it was it was
one element but he said the FBI didn't
do anything wrong Russia did something
wrong we're all entitled our own
opinions and I'm a big fan of the
senator but in this case we have
followed this very closely
we you suggesting he hasn't well I'm not
saying I'm not saying that I'm just
saying that if this is what this is the
way the FISA courts are going to be
behaved if this is that you can take
political dirt open up investigations
into political campaigns this is how a
democratic republic falls apart it's
it's just unexcited
in their right mind if the shoe was on
the other foot right down the street
here you would have protests in the
street cars being blocked fires in the
street tires mean
and I guarantee all the heads would have
rolled already at FBI and DOJ and you'd
have all the major news paper all the
major media saying what a crime this was
it let this happen
what's that footnote a cya footnote for
the so they so they could say look we we
reference this this was someone who
didn't like candidate number one we
referenced it because they did go on as
a way to put that in the footnote that's
why and that's why it's so that's why I
think you make a very good point and
this is what I was trying to say earlier
you have to really desperately try to
put the words together the way that they
did instead of just having a simple
definition which could have been
candidate to hired hired fusion GPS
right or us person one to hire source
one to go get the information that was
really simple to explain the courts
would have understood it easily and I
think the courts would have at that
point well they should have rejected I'm
not sure they would have but they should
have four Republican appointees judges
federal district court judges four yeah
I don't blame the judges I think that
judges were misled you don't think they
should have asked more questions I mean
if I if I saw well it's hard it's like
that was a prominent forget saying if it
was the majority of the case to open up
this warrant but if I saw a political
opposition
mm-hmm I would have asked more questions
who is this political opposition sadly
we don't yeah you should have asked that
but also sadly we don't have we don't
have any transcripts so we don't believe
there are any transcripts from those
hearings the left is saying in some
neoconservative saying you and your
committee have done an enormous amount
of damage to the FISA process that
putting all all this out there pushing
this issue as it is will ultimately
compromise our national security because
people are not going to be willing to
put themselves out to give information
to keep America safe they were gonna say
that and indeed they've been saying that
forever so remember when we first let's
just we got to call it how it is when we
first were writing the memo they said oh
my god he's gonna destroy the whole
process he's gonna disclose sources and
methods this is the end of the work this
is the end of the whole process did that
happen no and in fact once we released
the memo what did they do they said oh
my god he took four hundred pages and
got it down to three pages well yeah
because it was a memo and we were
under we were under strict you know kind
of confines to try to keep it as short
as possible and by the way the
redactions in this document documents
their significant and it does discuss
prior investigations however into Carter
page they've been watching him for some
time so doesn't that indicate that they
actually is information on page he was
meeting these conferences had some
contact with government officials they
had ample ample reason along with pepid
appleís to open up an investigation that
was what your critics are saying harder
page so foreign agent was not a foreign
agent and what did the FBI do back in
two thousand fourteen and fifteen
they wouldn't interviewed the guy that
would have been the place to start you
don't open up an investigation and into
a campaign okay and then turn around and
get a FISA warrant so that you could go
in and grab a lot of information that
had to have come from the campaign I
mean this is this is how back in
thirteen and fourteen they ran an
investigation the way it's supposed to
be run and don't forget another thing
that wasn't told to the court they did
not want to tell the court that Carter
page actually had cooperated with the
FBI in the past and that he had also the
Russians didn't even want to recruit him
because they thought he was an idiot
that was those are the Russians words
not not anybody else's the Russians said
that so there were a lot of reasons to
believe that Carter page was not acting
as some type of foreign agent what's
next for you on this we want the we want
the President to take care of the rest
of these read actions so that there's
full transparency and sunlight for
everyone to see and then we've sent 42
names over to chairman Gowdy and
chairman Goodlatte and we believe those
interviews will be starting soon
congressman thanks so much for stopping
by really appreciate it